TODD: IT IS NOT A BORDER STATE
PROBLEM, RON DESANTIS SAID THEY
ARE FLOCKING TO FLORIDA FROM THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> 70% OF PEOPLE THEY
INTERDICTED SAID THEIR ULTIMATE
DESTINATION WAS THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
IF YOU THINK HAVING WIDE-OPEN
BORDER 1000 MILES DOESN’T AFFECT
HERE YOU ARE WRONG.
TODD: OF FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
JUST RETURNED AND JOINS ME LIVE
TO TELL US ABOUT IT.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU ABOUT
GOVERNOR DESANTIS’S WARNING.
>> I AM TERRIFIED, THE TO KEEP
EVERY AMERICAN UP AT NIGHT
BECAUSE IN THE FACE OF THE SPORT
A CRISIS EVERY SINGLE TOWN IN
AMERICA IS A BORDER TOWN.
EVERY TOWN IN AMERICA IS A
BORDER TOWN, WE KNOW THAT NOT
JUST FROM THE ILLEGALS THAT HAVE
BEEN APPREHENDED AND RELEASED
INTO THE COMMUNITIES BUT THE
NARCOTICS.
IF YOU LOOK AT NARCOTICS
CONFISCATED AT THE BORDER IT’S
ENOUGH TO KILL EVERY MAN, WOMAN
AND CHILD 9 TIMES OVER.
THAT IS JUST FENTANYL.
THIS IS A CRISIS OF EPIC
PROPORTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING
THE GOVERNOR HIT ON IT.
THOSE BEING APPREHENDED AND
RELEASED THEY ARE DESTINED FOR
FLORIDA.
IN MY DISTRICT I RETURN FROM THE
BORDER WITH 6 SHERIFFS FROM OUR
AREA, THEY ARE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN CRIME IN ACTIONS OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION, WE LOST
93,000 AMERICANS TO OVERDOSES,
THAT NUMBER IS GOING TO
SKYROCKET, WE ARE SEEING THAT
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
SAID IF YOU ARE FROM ANY OTHER
COUNTRY, 140 NATIONALITIES IN
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER EXCEPT FOR
CUBA, WHAT THEY WERE VERY CLEAR,
SECRETARY MAYORKAS WAS CLEAR DO
NOT COME HERE IF YOU’RE FROM
CUBA BUT IF YOU ARE FROM
ANYWHERE ELSE, THROUGH THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER, IT IS A
WELCOMING PARTY.
THE MOST EXPENSIVE WELCOMING
PARTY I HAVE EVER SEEN, I
WITNESSED IT FIRSTHAND STANDING
ON THE BANKS OF THE RIVER AND IT
IS HEARTBREAKING.
YOU CANNOT BEGIN TO PROTECT YOUR
HOMETOWN IF YOU CANNOT DEFEND
THE HOMELAND AND THAT STARTS
WITH BORDER SECURITY.
>> IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTION THE
POINT YOU JUST MADE CUBA VERSUS
EVERY PLACE ELSE BECAUSE HUMAN
AMERICANS BY AND LARGE FOR